ouais alors depuis plusieurs mois les
affaires d'agressions sexuelles visant
des célébrités se multiplient ce matin
on a appris que le chanteur doc gynéco
notre amie
monique heures chez nous était visé par
des accusations aussi il a été placé
mercredi en garde à vue dans le cadre
d'une enquête préliminaire pour
agression sexuelle sur mineur de moins
de 15 ans regardez la vidéo de baisse et
les faire remonter ce mercredi bruno
beausir alias doc gynéco a été entendu
par les enquêteurs de la st 93 la sûreté
territoriale du département de la seine
saint denis dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire pour agression sexuelle sur
mineur de moins de 15 ans l'artiste le
chanteur de 47 ans a été placé en garde
à vue ce mercredi pour je cite des faits
délictueux de nature sexuelle est que la
mesure de la garde à vue a été levée
dans la soirée de ce mercredi à cette
heure aucune charge aucune poursuite
n'est engagée aux retenues contre doc
gynéco qui est libre à cette heure ci
alors moi j'ai des infos qui arrive
myriam qualification les infos que vous
avez alors il ya eu un signalement qui a
été fait et qui voit là encourager
la police à faire une enquête
préliminaire et donc à auditionner
dominicaux pendant neuf heures mercredi
ont effectivement il a été relâché
totalement mais ce serait pour des faits
délictueux d'ordre sexuel sur une
mineure qui n'aurait que douze ans la
maman et la jeune femme et la jeune
fille ont été entendus par la police
mais pour l'instant aucune plainte n'a
été déposée et doc gynéco et a été
relâché les livres alors moi ça il ya
quelqu'un qui me dit je vous le dis je
viens de croiser doc gynéco et que tu
appelles ce week-end sa réaction je n'ai
pas été mis en garde à vue j'ai été
auditionné pendant trois heures comme
vous dites et par les policiers qui
m'ont laissé repartir sans poursuites
tout ça ce sont des conneries donc
apparemment voilà il a été relâché doc
gynéco voilà et que apparemment il se
serait à xiii a poursuivi n'est pas
fausse paris a quand même énorme qu'il
ya quand même le parquet de bobigny qui
fait une enquête
il ya quand même un signalement donc
voilà les choses sont peut-être pas fini
mais pour l'instant effectivement il est
libre oui j'ai peur d'oublier son avocat
nous a dit à aux équipes et à moins
qu'il n'y a pas de plainte donc voilà
s'abrite derrière qu'il n'ya pas de
plainte mais il ya eu un signalement
quand même sérieux pour qu'effectivement
la fillette puisque 12 ans et sa maman
soit entendue et le parquet au vu de la
fère et au vue de l'audition qui je
confirme l'info a duré trois heures
s'est donné un délai de réflexion pour
examiner d'éventuelles suites
judiciaires à donner dire que c'est pas
éteint pour le moment il n'est pas
poursuivi mais on saura dans les
prochaines heures ou prochains jours si
une suite judiciaire ou pas parce que
voilà mes rêves la question qui ont
envie de vous poser on a l'impression
qu'il a à faire
comment ça se fait ça mais qu'est-ce qui
est ce qui fait qu à tous les jours où
on appris hier de ne pas être question
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les les jeunes
filles parlent plus facilement dans le
métier c'est quand même quelque chose
qui était assez courant est connu sauf
qu'on n'avait pas nous ont pas se
pressent des témoignages des gens qui
nous parlaient et c'est aujourd'hui
connue c'est quoi c'est comme une
réponse est non il y avait au moins un
mois j'ai vu des choses je dis pas que
j'en ai vécu mais j'ai vu des choses où
effectivement il y avait des voilà des
relations entre personnes connues et
deux inconnus qui était quand même très
bizarre et qu'il aurait pu être
condamnée par la loi aujourd'hui avec
tout ce qui est mis tous les jeunes
femmes parlent davantage elle parle
aussi davantage à la presse ce qui
n'était pas le cas il ya encore quatre
cinq ans donc c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui toutes ces affaires
ressort après effectivement il faut
faire attention parce que on a plus
l'impression que voilà c'est aujourd'hui
n'importe qui peut dire n'importe quoi
sur quelqu'un que personne est
auditionné facilement imaginons à la doc
gynéco voilà il est bien là il a été
entendu l'imaginons qui rien ça va
rester cette affaire dos collé quand il
fait des rires oh ça va rester après
vous savez enfin pour pour pour faire ce
métier de façon faim depuis assez
longtemps il ya des news et des news il
ya des noces lice rajouter ça bonjour ma
part à peu aussi aux oubliettes assez
rapidement souvent